a great sense of pride yes Smith jr. on
the baseline picks it out was minute
exactly right I mean he just you talk
about the verticality that is an
emphatic twice on the pipes look at how
fast off his feet he is it was wide open
at the confidence to kill her and
finally saw him and delivered six nine
[Music]
who slams it down these first few games
moonstone ain't got the easy beat up
topper Booker waved in mid-october
played a key role getting some big
minutes their legs is 18 it takes them
sweet feet inside of Jackson of these
exams he an unbeaten Denver Nuggets
eight deep post position
and by his money TJ Warren how many big
guys like that you know could make that
back what makes them virtually
unguardable in the paint nice ship pass
to the cutting Mikael bridges from
DeAndre 18 again it speaks to the
overall awareness is just a feathery so
that it'll flow beautiful time this
season leading it here down the stretch
output marquel floats in and Brett has
shown remarkable patience you know you
can overreact and not getting out of the
gates the way you want or you could
specially for two instinct with his
words shot clock down to three balanced
unis have it sit all right back to the
quarters ye with a big block eatin right
there did not move on the place stay
right there
[Applause]
[Music]
oops sends it down the only score double
figures in 313
he's been nude hookers pass and heavy
traffic
I hate them tied up kicks it out to a
wide-open Devon Tucker who knocks it
down
here is Irving on the captured shoot
comes up short on that one but Baynes
has been active on the glass but nice
job defensively there by bridges up
ahead to Canaan terrific fast-break
batches great recognition here from
Devin Booker the turnover now go don't
look great recognition
maybe there's the best example of a guy
to look at look at the tape Aidan with a
pretty spin inside of the nice reverse
goes out scored Phoenix here in this
quarter HT 2 9 8 and pet deep mode
position kicks it out to Josh Jackson
knock down another three sons missing on
the free throw Wooper llama can update
with that one just a little beyond reach
stay with it and then
grabs himself for the touches like this
straight bagging him down and they have
to understand you gotta keep fighting
this beautiful feet over the top from
Devin Booker he's known for his
defensive abilities now hit seven starts
as Aten over the top and quickly slams
it down last two games for personal
reasons and you hope his conditioning is
going to be solid and he's excited to
play lob up top hooker to 18 that a
quick slam gets his dirty this past year
trying to get out of there but nice pass
by Devin Booker as I said with a more
favorable match here boss board again
against Johnson just a nice soft touch
by eight
the student then liquor with the
deflection into the hands of a teen for
the slam
see the defense right there it's two
sons
fine Anton his side
[Applause]
maybe not
he knocks him down for three Jamal
Crawford thumps it inside the I play a
tree outside to Elisha never a reason
for free big possession big possession
and that's a hard fight they've got two
guys that can post up and they just lull
you to sleep and nice drive by look
around the give-and-go
there you see that lengthen reach of
Mariana [ __ ] with an apron returns a
favor on Gilda's Alexander Melton on the
drive finds eight
[Applause]
Milton 17 points seven rebounds six
assists Forbes inside and Aidan sittin
right back into the baseline of the
block bills
they need to do hurt or Smith is right
with him
sets him up now each of the Andre here
nice drop off and he just takes phrasing
rate at Jordan he's attacking his feet
and that's what you've got to do you
don't want to play a lane to strength
game here comes the anthony melt pounds
fell down
I think the scores but Josh Jackson
possibly good
smartphones are threats Latino the eight
new goes to the tenth floor and foul
chance at a three-point slay by eighty
times have we seen this from Jamaal
where he passes the ball in a crowd we
gonna have to go Suns right there chance
to win
that's a good finish there from 8 right
there they're taking this Russian battle
lizards expect it because wall is out
executing right there with said Oransky
takes his seats Warren on the LOB eight
and kind of missed time did initially
but not tapped back to him and the slams
at home wants backdoor action and watch
this down boom
Booker with a left hand
[Music]
Dave his father Terry played ten-year
NBA career last dead ball for Augustine
the fruits of its going at the road ke
leads it at the top and swats it out of
bounds
he's like elite like a seven footer when
he gets in the paint
quick look inside the 18 go quickly
slammed it down in space he likes to his
feet and once start last year
that's 31st
tonight's is a tea leaping over the top
with a new brain stepping in is this
alright second team foul court is almost
over the rebound
Aten runs the floor and hop out that one
underneath the rim he takes a peek up
you'll get to the rebound
warrants running through heavy traffic
in the Nate trailing there to swat it
out of bounds
good transition defense and all that I
just kind of wish he could just maybe
138 to go 8 inside fouled from behind
but cadet more chance at a three-point
play for the andre as we get an update
on Devin Booker from Lindsey Smith he's
safe over there
one-point game after the three free
throws by Jamal Crawford and eight
none of that from Kevin Walker get that
ball over the rim the only way that's
going in Caray is Daniels give chase
Aten rips it away over the steel GU
bring on his way to the rack
coaching staff take we'll take all the
credit
four-time all-star four straight years
in Atlanta he was an all-star for the
Hawks eight roles and put it in water
for DeAndre 18 with a strong start again
that's a great pass there when you catch
the andre boards in the first half no
second chance points another steal the
thief De'Anthony Melton flips it up
comes off on the chase was Josh kept in
a lot into the technical DeAndre and he
understands he's out of that perimeter
he's over plan he's taking chances this
is the part that he's got to get better
at and he will just finishing these
opportunities but will he come from
behind a lot this year and win close
games
Plumlee on a Coco all alone eight
elevates and detonates got the steel
they extended their defense and because
Plumlee was chasing and half-court
it allowed to just be right underneath
all bombs young coming off the screen
gets that one cent rate back to the
baseline seats there's a pick-and-roll
and Aten does a nice job stained Dayton
calling for it gets it a nice soft touch
over the top accounts what a nice jump
bucket he's so pretty at that people
cannot stay in front of him
12 you're not allowed to touch the guy
off the dribble it's hard to do
to me try difficult fast I can turn into
a layup going the other way Rockets turn
it over Jackson runs it right to the
[Music]
bender again beating inside to eight
able to bust one away takes it right to
the rabbit in it's rarely a cold game no
sometimes cold quarter sometimes you
fold half the date get spoon-fed again
with the Thompson locked up is d8 steps
in and look out the freight train
ruffles to the rim
Aidan wanted an opportunity to work on
montrezl harrell here tough turnaround
and DA looking for the n1 but he'll take
the hoop
you can see butcher drawing the
double-team attention whether he's
working the baseline or way out on the
perimeter whose get a nice opportunity
to run their own pick-and-roll right
here in sham it can't get in the way
soon enough and not much on the screen
but you saw
[Music]
the rim is going to be shaking for the
next 20 minutes after that DeAndre slams
the five now has he regains the scoring
lead over Ben Simmons Green give it good
cooperate with the emphatic flush to
early touches for the big fella shooting
37% overall almost 39 percent that is
short stem here moon Milwaukee Aten on
the spin ditch the whole role somehow
gets it back after the goofball then
just completely smothered by the two
suns defenders 82 anyway junior hooker
back to Johnson sets fire what they did
there in the first quarter they shot his
30% agent takes the feet over the top
pan will look for the three-point play
and after these silences went crazy they
often become those devastating
eight with a pretty turnaround on Durant
and Durant just kind of look at that II
like up and just reach out and grab you
gonna get a lot of positions where you
have to get back well look at that shot
there and the rent light get the reset
on the shot clock
boyd signing the big fella brady
turnaround of eight he just becoming
really unstoppable when he has a foot in
the tank the bear trying to turn the
corner eight and meets him at the top in
his career and they beat on the drive
it's stored away by melting it gets tied
up they find the training great
recognition there from Devin Booker got
caught up little couldn't attempt a good
shot here there's really nowhere to go
but defense there from Harrison you
expect that from him and gets the fishes
to react to what is the balance in that
I think that he has to contend
Crawford diving in comes away with a
steal
finds Daniels spinning dodo triathlon
for me I'll run the spark triathletes
very difference its Booker taking a
little more frustration on the rim and
they like you lives Austin any energy at
all 30 when the triple-double
eight-nothing drive inside spun around
give us the finish of the file you gotta
hit on the forearm they don't look like
trend
points shooting made is 227 hours
Jackson cut the sword
[Music]
follow the side and the 5va really spent
another offseason on those weeks and he
shows up next year
no nice feet over the top and Aten
wheels had just slams over the top of go
pair should definitely keep on file
therefore da yeah because it is duct
that's signed on with the Wizards back
early September is 80 takes a soft beat
up top right here that's just really
getting the tension all the way back in
this game
Jamal with a terrific 30-minute run
against the Wizards at 80 smothers the
chakra balance UNIX what's up you guys
this Taylor Brooks with bleacher report
make sure that you subscribe for some
more video content